Mời khách điểm thuộc phạm vi át dùng sẽ được cấp má định dành nhằm phân Việt và những ý định khác.
Các đối tượng thuộc dành mục biên bắt nhả nước không thuộc phạm vi điều trình của nghỉ định.
Đăng truy fact phạm vi đối tượng được định dành rất giống.
Uống thử đã công trình kiến chúc, công trình xây dân, kết cầu xây dân, điện dành các cầu chúc vật li và những lối tượng khác theo dành mục cầm thông nghỉ định.
Mỗi điểm chỉ được cấp một má định dành duy nhất màu đam không trung lập trong toàn hiện thống
và tôn thuộc cầu chúc thông nhất trên phạm vi cả nước.
Thằng ý định và hài sau, má định dành định điểm là giải số tuyên của 12 triệu số
gió cơ sở, giữ liệu định dành định điểm sau lập sau khi được tạo lập và gắn với mỗi đối tượng của thế,
má định dành phạm bảo đam tính ô định lâu dài.
Dự cấp má được thực hiện trên cơ sở, giữ liệu từ cắt cơ sở, giữ liệu cú ra và cơ sở, giữ liệu trên ngành bảo đam kế thưa, nông bộ và thống nhất.
Các làm này được khi vọng tạo nên tạo để liên kế thông tin giữa cắt cơ sở, giữ liệu,
hạn chế tình trạng giữ liệu phân tắng và hỗ trợ của trên quản lý, khải thác thông tin về địa điểm.